how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course everything relating to the MCU
today we're going to talk about quite
possibly the strongest mutant ever but
definitely one of the most powerful
Marvel Comics characters ever created
and talk about how the Fantastic Four
come into the MCU which we know is
something that is going to be happening
within the next two to five years so to
speak how their arrival is going to
eventually bring this mutant to the MCU
and also take a step back and look at
everything that we know so far about the
future of the MCU and what has happened
in the past we can see how the way for
this character to enter the MCU has
already begun to be paved and it has
ties to ant-man in the wasp ant-man
three the Wanda vision series coming up
and Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness as well if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
content relating to the MCU and I am
less than 2000 subscribers away from
giving away an Xbox one or ps4 so be
sure to subscribe so the way has been
paved for the Fantastic Four to enter
the MCU Kevin Feige himself has even
mentioned it at San Diego comic-con that
they are coming along with the mutants
and in our case we are kind of talking
about both the arrival of Reed Richards
Sue Storm Johnny Storm and Ben Grimm -
the MCU is also going to eventually
bring another character to the MCU many
of the comic readers already know who
I'm talking about and that is Franklin
Richards the son of Reed Richards and
Sue Storm yes in the comics mr.
fantastic and The Invisible Woman do
have children and not only do they have
children but Franklin Richards is one of
the most powerful mutants and characters
to ever come into existence and as I
mentioned before the way is currently
being paved for him to enter the MCU
which we'll talk about but first let's
talk about his powers and what makes him
one of the most powerful characters ever
because he's so powerful that at one
point in time he basically uses Galactus
himself as his personal puppet now
Franklin as a child is actually a pretty
moderate and dormant for the most part
child with his powers only being
telepathy and telekinesis but the story
of how he gets his powers are actually
quite remarkable Sue Storm is pregnant
with Franklin at the time but she is
dying she's dying due to the cosmic
energy that originally gave her and the
rest of the Fantastic Four team their
power
and Franklin from insight is feeding off
of this energy and her own life energy
so in order to save her and the baby
Reed Richards says that they have to go
inside of the negative zone which is
very similar to the quantum realm in the
MCU
and retrieve antimatter that will save
her the Human Torch and the thing say
that mr. fantastic can't go alone so the
three of them go into the negative zone
there they encounter Annihilus with the
cosmic control rod they eventually
defeat him and they realized that the
cosmic control rod is what they need to
save Sue Storm they take it back and
they're able to use the cosmic control
rod to essentially balance the energy
inside of Sue Storm and Franklin is born
and everything is okay now the cosmic
control rod is used to give the holder
the ability to manipulate matter and
energy and it also gives them power over
cosmic energy and Franklin gets some of
his powers from the cosmic control rod
since it was used to save his mother and
him but he is also officially deemed a
mutant in the House of M storyline The
Scarlet Witch says no more mutants and
she reduces the mutant population by 90%
there's only a hundred and something
mutants left after she says this but the
comic does say that Franklin Richards
is indeed a mutant and he is one of the
survivors now again as a very little
child his powers were pretty simple and
basic but he would have flare-ups here
and there for example one time Norman
Osborn when he was the head of shield
came to the Baxter building and was
threatening mr. fantastic who of course
is his father Franklin was holding a toy
gun and he told us born to leave and
when he didn't he squeezed the trigger
and a real bullet came out and he shot
Norman Osborn in the arm this was a sign
of his mater manipulation and his
reality manipulation abilities because
there is a difference between matter
manipulation and reality manipulation
which we'll get into in just a second
now where his powers truly start to
develop is when a future version of
himself comes to visit him his future
self comes to visit his past self
because in the future his father mr.
fantastic is dying so he came to awaken
the powers of his past self that way he
can stop whatever is causing his father
to die his powers are now awakened and
his matter manipulation and reality
manipulation begin he starts to create
entire universes under his blanket at
night and his future self comes back and
starts to teach him how to harness and
use
powers they create a blank universe
which is basically a universe where the
two of them just learn so he starts to
learn how to create things he creates
Suns planets solar systems and even life
he basically becomes God and creates
entire universes eventually a group of
Celestials called the mad Celestials
come from a different timeline and they
end up destroying Galactus and here's
where we learned why the Future Franklin
Richards had been coming back in time to
teach the current Franklin Richards and
that is because all of the power that
has been building up in the young
Franklin Richards over time he has been
taking so he takes all of the power that
has been built up over time of his
younger past self and he gives it to
himself and he essentially doubles the
amount of power that he has he's so
powerful that the Celestials don't even
recognize him as Franklin Richards they
recognize him as an omega-level mutant
so they're trying to figure out just who
he is and they're going over thanks
saying reality distortion Universal
shaper galactic constant danger danger
doom what they now recognize him as this
universal omnipotent being and he's so
powerful that he actually raises
Galactus from the dead he brings him
back to life and then Galactus serves as
his servant and then the two of them
attack and defeat the Celestials
together with ease the fight is over
very very soon Franklin Richards is
destroying Celestials by himself with
one single punch and then commanding
Galactus as a puppet as well to kill the
Celestials so as you can see he is an
insanely powerful mutant probably the
strongest mutant to ever be created in
the Marvel Comics universe now
unfortunately when we eventually get
Franklin Richards they're definitely
going to have to nerf him he's not going
to be able to have all of these powers
naturally they'll probably give him
telepathy and telekinesis but reality
warping is really Opie just think about
fantasy and the Infinity Gauntlet it had
massive power in Avengers infinity war
and Avengers endgame but it was nerved
from how powerful it was in the comics
and the comics Thanos snapped half of
the universe out of existence with ease
and he there continued to defeat all of
the x-men and Avengers and then take on
the cosmic beans themselves all without
the gauntlet or himself being harmed and
it's going to be the same thing for
Franklin Richards when he eventually
enters the MCU they're gonna nerf him
down a little bit so let's talk about
the
work in the MCU that has already been
laid in the future groundwork that will
be laid for him to enter the MCU to
start off with the way he originally
gets his powers is because his father
Reed Richards mr. fantastic has to go
into the negative zone to collect
antimatter which is supposed to heal him
this sounds pretty familiar doesn't it
just think of the negative zone like the
quantum realm because in the MCU that's
most likely what it's going to be and we
learned from ant-man and the wasp that
the quantum realm has certain healing
factors and in the post-credits scene
for ant-man and the wasp we learned that
you could collect those healing
particles from the quantum realm now the
Fantastic Four have a deep connection
with the negative zone and what is
called the Microverse which is actually
the quantum realm in the MCU they've
spent a lot of time in there and it's
widely believed that that's how they're
going to be making their MCU debut so
eventually in the MCU when sue gets
pregnant and her life is at jeopardy mr.
fantastic and the rest of the Fantastic
Four can go inside the quantum realm to
collect the healing particles and then
of course there's the cosmic control rod
now not much has been said about a
nihilist
entering the MCU but one person who has
been said to be coming very soon is Kang
the Conqueror
now Kang's base which is called
kanopolis exists in the comics in a
place called limbo it's a place where
time exists kind of differently much
like the quantum realm and it's widely
believed that the city inside of the
quantum realm that we saw in ant-man and
the wasp that's where King is and that's
Crenn Oppel as' and there could very
well be the power cosmic inside of that
city and another thing is that when
Franklin Richards was a child his
parents gave him to Agatha Harkness so
she could look after him for a while
they didn't fully give him up but when
they were working and when they went on
missions Agatha Harkness looked after
him and Agatha from afar using her
witchcraft powers would end up helping
the Fantastic Four several times on
several different missions warning them
about danger now if you're wondering why
Agatha Harkness is a familiar name it's
because she also helped train The
Scarlet Witch in fact she announced that
she was quitting being the governess of
Franklin Richards because she had to go
help tutor the Scarlet Witch so
essentially she left Franklin for Wanda
and it's pretty much all but confirmed
that Kathryn Hahn is going to be playing
her in the one division show we have
leaked photos of Kathryn Hans character
and what looks to be the Salem witch
trials and these are photos leaked
directly from the set of one division so
we know that echo the Harkness is going
to play a pretty big role in the
television show so it could be possible
that in the timeline of the MCU before
she ends up with Wanda for whatever
reason in the one division show she
could have been with Franklin Richards
before because we all think that right
now the Fantastic Four as a group
currently exists in the MCU we just
haven't seen them yet
Fox has already done the origin story
for the Fantastic Four and it's widely
believed that Disney's gonna change it
up a little bit but as I mentioned right
now there are many factors in the MCU
that could one bring in the Fantastic
Four which we know is going to be
happening relatively soon and to bring
in Sue Storm and mr. fantastics child
Franklin Richards and when this happens
the most powerful mutant to ever be
created by Marvel Comics will be in the
MCU now again of course he'll be nerfed
a little bit and he won't have all of
these vast cosmic powers to just be able
to control everything at will but no
doubt he will be a very powerful mutant
and the MCU so let me know what you
think about this do you think that
Franklin Richards should be nerfed and
if so what powers do you think that he
should retain in the MCU let me know in
the comments down below and don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up-to-date on everything relating to the
MCU for live updates on MCU news you can
follow me on Twitter and as always thank
you all so much for watching we'll fall
off